[Music]
earlier today CEO I've said a Projekt
RED Adam Kachinsky said this year and
the next one will be the year of The
Witcher so putting a credence to the
idea that they won't be talking about
cyberpunk 2077 until 2017 Justin this is
a game that we first saw in January of
2013 via that trailer with that rad song
and that cyberpunk lady what do you
think about them not talking or
unveiling anything else about this game
for another two calendar years it's in a
way it makes sense they're they've put a
lot into The Witcher not just with the
DLC coming up but expansions that
they're not being completely forward
with but we know those are coming as
well so in that way it's heartening like
they're putting a lot into The Witcher
and it's not going to be a an experience
which is lessened by working on these
other games but at the same time it's
that's a long time to be working on this
game and any time you know it doesn't
necessarily mean something negative it
could have gone through lots of
different changes we haven't seen a lot
out of it so is this something that's
gonna make it better did it go through
some troubles or did it just have to be
restarted at some point yeah I mean you
guys were at the studio recently is that
yeah they make into that it all new did
you get to talk to us about it one of
the so we saw a bunch of stuff at CD
Projekt when we were there shooting
that's not the building that's that's
their studio right behind it was built
by the Soviets well yeah when we were at
there I'm at their studio in in Warsaw
there was a couple of little things we
saw yeah a poster mainly yeah there was
one room we went into where they
straight-up told you to stop filming
yeah they're like just put your camera
down scribble walk through here they're
still working on The Witcher though they
weren't like working on that cyberpunk
game yet it didn't seem like so what we
heard was there was like a mission
statement we talked about this before
yeah and it just sounded awfully
ambitious we sort of scanned that they
said that the the cyberpunk team had
been working I'm not sure if it was in
the separate buildings they did have
another building but they said that they
pulled in everyone yeah of course The
Witcher had been delayed I think three
times by that stage and they said that
they pulled in everyone from that team
to finish and with your wild hunt and we
went into one of the rooms yeah there
was this Poe
the two of us kind of looked at it and
scanned it as much as I tried to
remember as much of it as possible and
the only thing I could remember was like
open-world role-playing so it kind of
sounded like witcher 3 except paul
choice like branches storyline and
whether this ends up being what it is we
don't know but you have to think if
they're gonna spend all that time making
that engine making that type of game the
cyberpunk 2077 is a good chef is gonna
be a game similar to The Witcher 3 in
some sort of mechanics and then you get
that other audience that isn't
necessarily taken in by the fantasy
traffic yeah that love is that science
fiction world they in the same way that
Blizzard does with World of Warcraft and
Starcraft yeah both of those audiences
yeah because this is like the first like
big mainstream CD Projekt success like
you played all the other widget games in
the past and well yeah like talk about
trying to have not like we'll have one
of those hipster reviews about things
the man you all coming on which
bandwagon now but man I've been there
since beginning no but it's awesome to
see them keeping to their freaking
vision man like Witcher has been such a
good game each time it gets even better
and they've like reached a game they got
a ten out of ten on our site like the
reach the pinnacle status basically
right and now they're poised to do
another game but I think the important
thing too I don't know how games are
made right so I do know that Studios
other Studios that make these
quote-unquote triploid games have like
one team working on this yeah that
overlaps with this and then it's like
now we have a release calendar so we can
talk about this at e3 and we'll have
this schedule to go and then blah blah
blah blah blah
CD Projekt is it doesn't seem to care
and they're there of their own publisher
as well which is super important so then
they go let's make the best game we can
make they made Witcher 3 they had to
pull in everybody like you said you
finish it and then they're like alright
so now let's make the best game we can
make again yep Syfy and now it's going
to take and they're like let's you know
what let's just not talk about it for
three years because we don't need to
like you know what we can do let's just
make it and they're gonna gonna go do
that which is super exciting like like
it is a long time man but we were
talking to them about The Witcher 2 and
Mark [ __ ] Nowitzki was saying about how
the biggest problem with two was that
they ran into money and there Ryan at a
time it was like a massive problem hell
because the ending of that game like
they stripped dead loads of stuff
well we're as well at homes clearly they
had enough time and resources to make
this game hopefully it's doing enough
successfully financially wise across
three platforms under console releases
the massive deal for them money-wise to
give them the time to make a really good
cyberpunk game but what another
interesting thing about it was when we
were doing the interviews like somebody
interviews were shot in this like lovely
like had like swords on the ceiling and
like a nice brickwork wall and then it
was like a media room and then there was
another media room and then there was
this other room that was all likewise
painted had a crazy futuristic me I
heard like neon lighting on the panels
yeah I'm not like joke that one of the
artists and was like what is this your
cyberpunk room and he went yeah so they
were already prepping and like people
were like the receptionist at the base
was Renaissance from 2077 shirt and like
loads people walking around with them
and it's I guess there was a four-year
gap between which it to and that was
2011 and so then if they announced well
I guess another four years from now
would be 2019 is that too long to wait
for that size of a developer 150 200
people yeah I wonder if they'll scale up
I don't know and then cheaper for any
kind of smaller developer as well like
as that game comes out then you know
that they'll be working on whatever
their next title will be maybe that'll
be another witch or maybe it'll be
something else entirely but you have to
have something that gives all the
different teams something to work on you
have you have people who only do art and
assets aren't actually coding and
creating these things and so once the
game is like fully in process like they
don't have as much to do on the game
itself they need to create these worlds
that the computer rendering guys are
gonna base it off of and then the
gameplay guys will be able to take that
and so being able to stagger projects
gives each of those teams something to
do without having to lay off yeah yeah
that's true
and I wonder like the artist seems to
get really good at making characters in
that medieval fantasy setting yeah they
built a sport they got real like you can
tell from the first game of the second
game of the three the the ramp up is
incredible now they have to do that
again I can start from the start and to
start yeah yeah with the new and a new
lore which doesn't have a sort of a
grounding like The Witcher did and you
know the in all the books I guess the
last thing to talk about a relation is
people are kind of bomb
thinking oh my god cyberpunk we might be
able to play it for like years and years
and years but then I guess the flip side
of this is that if they're saying that
this year and next year are the years of
The Witcher then what does that mean
does that mean they're gonna just make a
bunch of expansion packs that they're
gonna keep because that open world man
there's a lot of space left on that like
they're one of the expansion packs we
know is a new area does that mean it's
gonna be two years like almost Bethesda
style of alright here we go
operation hybrid all comes back again
that's an exciting process back Justin
yeah I think any time that you can get
that much out of a game it's like it's
it's exciting for me as a consumer that
I'm not just buying this game I'm buying
something that's gonna last me for the
next couple of years that it's not quite
on the scale of like an MMO something
that lasts me for for ten years but then
I get to play this game now and I don't
have to say goodbye to it when I finish
it yeah like maybe I'll get to take a
break and try it some other things and
then there's gonna be that next
expansion that pulls you in it makes it
a little bit more fun pulls out the lore
and makes it works I mean I love it when
they do stuff like that for for games
that are popular and I mean it also
means that the game is doing well like
that tells you like I made a good
investment in this game and a tea and
other people have as well yeah and the
more people to buy them the more I guess
they'll they'll plan to support this
game because they'll have a bigger user
base of people to purchase expansion
packs in DLC from a lot of people see
that as a as a negative like as a
money-grabbing thing but I think in the
way that modern games are created it's a
necessity like to be able to to build
games at this scale and for that amount
of money you have to have a plan that's
gonna stretch out for for at least a
year and as much as you might see like
an expansion is oh we're not done with
the game we had these ideas we're not
able to put them in we're gonna charge
you extra money for them like those are
extra things with The Witcher 3 and a
lot of other games you have a full
experience and this is literally like
which are one point are three point five
like it's a it's an additional thing
that to me is is worth it in this kind
of case Andy can you confirm this slide
reform 2077 will have bottlings oh man
future boxing future box yes but it
could happen that thing could still
happen people might you know not good
families connected maybe yeah there you
go yeah it'll be like Red Faction insane
it's all part of the same world it's our
[ __ ] established fiction I think it
is I have actually never I think they
are taking
yeah yeah huh cool just taking it all
guess we'll have to wait just another
couple years to find that and let us
know you think of cyberpunk 2077 let us
know what you'll be doing in 2077 when
the game comes out on PlayStation 15
[Music]